bonjour je vous invite voilà nous allons
poursuivre nos travaux et dans la le
prolongement de notre audition
précédente sur les familles parentales
je suis heureuse d'accueillir ce matin
des représentants du Secours Catholique
donc Raphaël Badaoui chargé d'études
statistiques co-auteur du rapport annuel
du Secours Catholique sur l'état de la
pauvreté en France intitulé cette année
pauvreté les femmes en première ligne et
qui met en exerg je cite une
féminisation de la pauvreté et une une
aggravation de la pré de la précarité
des femmes et Sophie rigard chargé de
projet action et plédoyer accès digne au
revenus bienvenue à vous le rapport
annuel que j'évoquais ainsi que plus
globalement les actions et l'expertise
de Secours Catholique nous intéresse à
double titre tout d'abord pour nos
travaux sur les familles monoparental
dont les rapporteurs sont colombe
Brossel et Béatrice goselin alors
qu'elle représente 9 % des ménages en
France les familles monoparentales
représentent 28 % des ménages rencontrés
par le Secours Catholique et les MRES
isoléses représentent 39 % des femmes
françaises rencontrées et 35 % des
étrangères les données de la knaf dont
nous venons de diionner des
représentants montrent que le niveau de
vie des familles monoparentales est
nettement inférieur à celui des autres
familles et que 41 % des familles des
enfants en famille monoparental vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté contre 16 %
des enfants dont les parents sont en
couple on se souvient qu'en 2018 pendant
la crise des gilets jaunes les mares
isolés avaient été nombreuses à occuper
les rond-points pour alerter sur leurs
difficultés vous nous présenterez le
profil et les difficultés des mèes
isolées accueillies par le Secours
Catholique ainsi que les mesures
nécessaires selon vous pour mieux les
accompagner certaines voix plaide pour
la mise en place d'un statut de par an
isolés qu'en
pensez-vous nous souhaitons également
vous entendre sur la problématique des
femmes dans la rue qui constitue notre
seconde thématique de travail cette
année nos rapporteurs sont les
sénatrices Agnès éen Marie Laur finerort
Olivia Richard ici présente et Laurence
Rossignol qui a dû partir dans le valde
Marne près d'un ménage sur tro accueilli
au Secours catholique en 2022 n'avait
pas accès à un logement stable cette
part a augmenté de 10 points entre 2010
et 2019 vous indiqué dans votre rapport
que même si les femmes restent un peu
mieux protégées contre le sansabrisme le
nombre de femmes et d'enfants à la rue
augmente et les situations précaires en
hébergement ou hôtel
s'éternisent on estime que 330000000
personnes sont sans domicile en France
aujourd'hui parmi elles 40 % de femmes
seules ou bien souvent avec des enfants
environ 3000 femmes dorment chaque nuit
dans la rue les autres sont hébergés en
centre d'hébergement d'urgence ou en
centre pour demandeurs d'asile ces
solutions sont temporaires et
incertaines chaque mois chaque semaine
chaque soir parfois il leur faut
rechercher une nouvelle place
d'hébergement sur ce sujet également
vous nous ferez part non seulement de
vos constats de terrain mais aussi et
surtout de vos
préconisations je laisse sans plus
tarder la parole à Raphaël Badaoui et
Sophie rigard je vous le dit
cette cette audition est captée voilà
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo à
vous monsieur Badaoui très bien merci
beaucoup et bonjour à toutes et à tous
euh on va commencer par une présentation
assez rapide des principaux résultats du
rapport notamment en accent sur les
problématiques qui nous intéressent
aujourd'hui
h juste en en propos introductif les
chiffres qu'on va vous présenter
aujourd'hui sont pas représentatifs bien
sûr de la France dans son entièreté on a
ici des chiffres qui sont représentatifs
des personnes accompagnées par le
Secours Catholique notamment en 2022
dans ce
rapport on estime qu'on accompagne et
rencontre à peu près un million de
personnes chaque
année je vais commencer par vous
présenter le profil général pour que
vous ayez un petit peu une meilleure
connaissance du du profil des personnes
qu'on accueille au-delà de des mèes
isolées mais ça ça vous permettra de
mieux appréhender les suite des constats
que je vais vous
présenter donc on on dresse un profil un
peu
démographique des situations par rapport
à l'emploi et des conditions de vie et
des ressources des personnes qu'on
accueille grâce à une une enquête
statistique qu'on produit tous les ans
euh et donc cette année mais c'est pas
une surprise c'est comme les années
précédentes on a une surreprésentation
des ménages composés d'un seul adulte et
c'est notamment les mères isolées qui
sont les ménages les plus les plus
rencontrés par le Secours Catholique
plus d'un quart des ménages qu'on
rencontre sont en fait des mèes isolé
euh pour aussi bien comprendre tous les
chiffres que je vais vous présenter
ensuite il faut avoir en tête qu'une
personne sur deux qui accueillli au
Secours catholique est de nationalité
étrangère euh environ un/3 sont sans
papier mais un/ers sont aussi dans des
situations avec des statuts
administratifs régularisé et d'autres en
attente d'une réponse pour pour leur
demande euh sur les dernières années
donc notamment en 2022 on a une hausse
de profil de Primot arrivant en France
c'est-à-dire arrivant en France depuis
moins d'un an euh notamment dû au
conflit en Ukraine euh pardon au conflit
en Ukraine et euh et donc une population
euh très euh très féminine beaucoup de
femmes qui sont venu avec leurs enfants
et notamment donc des des familles
monoparentales et puis la réouverture de
certaines frontières après le la période
covid et aussi euh c'est important de
l'avoir en tête mais en fait dans tous
les chiffres qu'on va vous présenter là
euh les personnes de nationalité
étrangère sont dans des situations de
précarité bien plus extrêmes euh que ne
le sont déjà celles de nationalité
française qu'on rencontre donc pour
illustrer ça on a noté ici que plus d'un
ménage étranger sur deux et sans aucune
ressource
financière euh par rapport à l'activité
c'est aussi important d'avoir ça en tête
là il y a il y a deux graphiques donc
celui de droite représente en France
entière et celui de gauche les personnes
rencontrées au Secours Catholique vous
voyez que la part de personnes en
situation dit d'inactivité c'est-à-dire
très éloigné de l'emploi donc sans
emploi et pas en recherche active
d'emploi euh h est très importante au
Secours Catholique 61 % mais surtout
très différente de celle rencontrée en
population générale on compte dans les
inactifs en France plutôt des retraités
et des étudiants au Secours catholique
c'est un tout autre profil c'est des
gens qui soit ont été découragé dans
leur recherche d'emploi soit sont en
inaptitude pour raison de santé soit N
tout simplement pas le droit au travail
en raison de leur statut administratif
et parmi les 17% 17 % de personnes qui
sont en emploi il y a une énorme
surreprésentation des emplois précaires
c'est-à-dire c'estd contrat court temps
partiel et cetera et on va en reparler
bien sûr vu notre
thématique enfin des principaux constate
notre rapport cette année c'est une
aggravation des situations des personnes
qu'on rencontre euh on peut pas vraiment
mesurer d'aggravation disons de
l'ampleur du phénomène de pauvreté comme
peut le faire Linc et comme elle l'a
documenté récemment en en publiant ces
taux de pauvreté qui avait augmenté
entre 2020 et 2021 nous on peut juste se
concentrer sur la situation des
personnes qu'on rencontre tous les ans
et on note que la situation s'est
dégradée euh notamment euh en raison de
l'inflation tous les indicateur de
niveau de vie de taux de pauvreté se
sont dégradés quand on prend en compte
l'inflation mais aussi on observe une
hausse de la part de ménag sans aucune
ressource et ça pour le coup ça n'a rien
à voir avec
l'inflation et maintenant on peut
rentrer dans dans le vif du sujet donc
je vais pas vous présenter toute la
partie thématique je vais essayer de
d'insister sur sur sur les points qui
nous intéressent donc notamment les les
les femmes vivant seul avec des enfants
euh juste pour un petit peu de contexte
on a fait ce rapport parce que et on a
choisi cette thématique parce que depuis
quelques années on observe une
augmentation de la part de femmes dans
nos accueils et une aggravation de leur
situation
euh une féminisation qui se traduit dans
les chiffres en donc il y a bien il y a
une trentaine d'années on était à peu
près à moitié de femmes moitié d'hommes
dans nos accueils donc comme en
population générale et aujourd'hui on
est à 57,5 % des adultes rencontrés qui
sont qui sont des
femmes cette hausse on on peut
l'expliquer de plusieurs manières donc
là on en a cité deux qui nous paraissent
les plus importantes euh la hausse de la
part de femmes parmi les étrangers
accueillis il y a encore 10 15 ans les
étrangers qui arrivaient en France et
qui étaient en en en difficulté en
situation de précarité étaient surtout
des hommes seuls ce n'est plus le cas
maintenant maintenant il y a beaucoup de
familles et de femmes avec leurs enfants
et le poids croissant des ruptures
conjugales et donc la charge des enfants
qui incomp toujours aux femmes
aujourd'hui donc parmi les femmes qu'on
rencontte plus d'un tiers sont des mères
isolées et 22 % des femmes seules et mèr
isolées qui qui viennent dans nos
accueils mentionnent une séparation un
abandon un divorce
récent on a en effet pas le même public
quand on parle des hommes qu'on
accueille et des femmes qu'on accueille
au Secours Catholique notamment en terme
de de situation par rapport à l'emploi
euh c'est des choses qu'on peut
retrouver en fait en situation générale
mais qui sont parfois exacerbés dans
dans cette part de de la population euh
bon par exemple on rencontre autant de
femmes que d'hommes qui soi en emploi 17
% des personnes des adultes qu'on
accompagne par contre il y a une très
nette surreprésentation des temps
partiels pour les femmes 34 % euh contre
16 % pour pour les hommes ça c'est des
des écarts qu'on retrouve aussi en
population population
générale mais les femmes sont quand même
plus souvent euh en situation
d'inactivité donc quand elles sont pas
en emploi elles sont pas en recherche
d'emploi non plus euh et c'est un
phénomène qui qui s'accroit notamment
entre 2021 et 2022 elles sont compte
plus de de points de pourcentage de
femmes dans cette situation et quand
elles sont dans cette situation elles
sont beaucoup plus souvent que les
hommes euh comme on dit au foyer euh
alors que les hommes sont que de % dans
cette situation les femmes sont plus de
de 11 % dans cette
situation vous l'avez cité en en en
introduction mais on observe une
dégradation des situations par rapport
au logement donc sur le long terme c'est
aussi dû au fait qu'on qu'on accueille
plus de population de nationalité
étrangère mais mais en plus de de
l'ampleur de personnes en en logement
précaire donc instable ici on regroupe
toutes les personnes qui ne sont pas
locataires ou propriétaires donc qui
vivent soit en hébergement d'urgence
soit à la rue soit chez un proche qui
les accueille pendant une certaine
période
h toute ce la part de personnes dans
cette situation augmente depuis 10 ans
au Secours catholique mais encore plus
inquiétant c'est l'allongement de la
durée passée dans les dans ces logements
instables donc c'est plus des
hébergements d'urgence finalement quand
on est à 1 an et demi de de moyenne dans
cette situation euh c'est c'est plus que
de
[Musique]
l'instabilité pour revenir à notre sujet
on a on a fait un un chapitre sur sur le
la situation des mères donc des ménages
féminins avec des des enfants à charge
parce que bon bah quand on regarde quand
on regarde nos chiffres c'est c'est
assez parlant la parentalité concerne
toujours plus les femmes que les hommes
94 % des enfants qu'on accompagne vivent
dans un ménage où une femme est présente
vous voyez sur le le schéma de droite là
c'est c'est tous les ménages donc les
familles les ménages avec des enfants il
y a seulement 6 ver ,7 % de pair isolées
donc c'est encore un un phénomène assez
rare donc on a voulu se concentrer sur
sur ces MRES isolées et et ces couples
avec enfants euh bien sûr dans nos
chiffres on observe des demandes
spécifiques de ces ménages qui ont des
enfants à charge plus de demandes lié à
des produits de première nécessité comme
l'alimentation les vêtements et bien sûr
l'accompagnement scolaire un petit peu
moins de demande li à l'emploi et et au
logement vous allez voir que notamment
les les M désolé sont les les types de
ménage qui sont les plus en activité
parmi les personnes qu'on rencontre donc
qui sont le plus souvent soit en emploi
soit à la recherche d'un emploi par
contre quand on s'intéresse au au couple
donc composé d'un homme et d'une femme
dans dans ce
cas-là lorsqu'il y a des enfants on
observe que l'écart de taux d'activité
entre l'homme et la femme est très
important c'est-à-dire que c'est bien
plus souvent l'homme qui a un emploi et
la femme qui est qui est donc au foyer
comme je disais tout à l' à l'heure ou
en tout cas qui n'est pas en recherche
d'emploi alors que dès que dans les
couples quand on compare au couples sans
enfants dans ces situations là euh il y
a pas d'écart significatif entre les
deux entre les deux adultes du couple
donc ça c'est c'est une observation un
peu à froid mais qui qui implique
beaucoup de choses notamment dans le cas
des séparations et
cetera euh du point de vue des
ressources et niveau de vie des des
ménages avec enfants on observe que
vivre avec les enfants semble limiter le
fait de percevoir aucune ressource
financière alors on essaie de d'avoir
quelques hypothèses d'explication
peut-être qu'on est mieux repéré par les
services sociaux qu'on a accès à
certaines aides plus facilement on l'a
notamment observé pendant la période
covid dans notre rapport précédent où
les les mè isolées ont on ont été un
petit peu plus protégés que que les
autres ménages euh mais par contre ça
accroit le risque de vivre sous le seuil
d'extrême pauvreté c'est-à-dire qu'on se
retrouve pas sans aucun
aucune ressource mais le fait d'avoir
des enfants à charge on pas on atteint
pas un niveau de vie suffisant pour pour
avoir des des conditions de vie
digne juste pour conclure on a fait une
petite
slide avec des chiffres sur les sur les
mers isolées donc il y a plusieurs focus
dans dans le rapport sur sur ces ménages
en en particulier donc les mes isolées
qu'on accueille bien sûr
euh on estime que c'est une précar été
de jeunes adultes avec un âge médien de
41 ans
mais on rencontre beaucoup de de jeunes
mères isolées euh 46 près de la moitié
des enfants qu'on rencontre vivent dans
dans ces ménages là vous l'avez déjà vu
euh 62 % sont françaises donc quand même
plus que le reste des personnes qu'on
accueille et comme je disais es sont
majoritaire elles sont majoritairement
actives euh c'est dans cette population
qu'on qu'on retrouve le plus de
personnes en emploi ou en recherche
d'emploi donc ça veut dire à la fois que
qu'elles sont obligé de de trouver un
emploi mais ça veut surtout dir que même
avec un emploi quand on est seul à
s'occuper d'un enfant on s'en sort pas
forcément et on est obligé de faire
appel à à des associations caritatives
comme le Secours Catholique voilà et
donc il y a d'autres chiffres sur cette
slide mais mais vous pourrez aussi
regarder dans le rapport directement euh
j'ai pas citer beaucoup de chiffres sur
la la problématique des des des femmes
en errance alors ça fera peut-être le
objet dans nos futurs rapports mais mais
on a on a tout à fait des des choses à
dire là-dessus je peux te laisser la
parole
Sophie merci beaucoup je vais essayer de
compléter rapidement sur des éléments de
proposition et de de recommandations
dans notre rapport au score catholique
on on s'attache à à écouter directement
les demandes que formulent les personnes
euh et donc que demandent ces femmes
notamment que que que l'on accueille
elles demandent à ce que elles sachent
où pouvoir loger le soir même euh
directement euh le soir même demain et
les mois qui viennent parce que c'est
concrètement la base donc c'est se
mettre à l'abri euh et donc ça ça nous
invite à à relever qu'il manque 20000
places d'hébergement d'urgence en France
aujourd'hui ça nous invite à à regarder
la question de la régularisation de la
situation administrative des personnes
exilées puisque c'est un frein énorme
notamment pour pour l'accès au logement
de de de femmes étrangères et de leurs
enfants euh la question de l'adaptation
du parc euh de de logement à la réalité
des besoins il y a un réel manque de de
d'un développement d'une offre locative
qui soit vraiment social en particulier
en
île-de-fance et ces femmes elles
demandent à pouvoir subvenir à leurs
besoins vitaux et à ceux de leurs
proches et notamment à protéger leurs
enfants ce qu'elle nous dit c'est
qu'elles sont prêtes à tous les
sacrifices et c'est ce qu'elles font
pour protéger leurs enfants puisque
c'est c'est pour leurs enfants qu'ell
poussent la porte du Secours Catholique
et de beaucoup
d'associations Solidar ité et elles sont
prêtes à manquer des repas voir à plus
pour payer une sortie scolaire à leurs
enfants et et et et les protéger de de
de de toute la violence que que que
représente la
précarité et pour ça ce que nous on ce
qu'on ce sur quoi on interpelle c'est
notamment la question de la rémunération
décente des personnes qui sont en emploi
mais pas pas que des personnes qui sont
sans emploi également puisque une partie
d'entre elles on l'a dit travaille mais
une partie d'entre ell aussi sont assez
éloigné du marché de l'emploi aussi
parce que avoir des enfants c'est
compliqué c'est c'est une un facteur
d'éloignement d' du marché de l'emploi
en tout cas ça peut être plus difficile
de retrouver un emploi de s'organiser de
trouver un mode de garde d'enfant et
cetera euh quand quand on a des enfant
ça peut être plus difficile d'avoir un
temps plein donc on est plutôt sur du
temps partiel donc aussi des des revenus
moins importants euh les rémunérations
des femmes qui sont structurellement
moins importantes que celles des hommes
euh des métiers qui sont aussi moins
valorisés moins reconnu euh elles sont
beaucoup dans les métiers du soin euh et
là aussi on interpelle sur la question
de euh de de voilà de la rémunération
décente de de des métiers que
qu'occupent ces femmes euh la question
on l'a dit de enfin je l'ai pas vraiment
mentionné mais il y a la situation
administrative des personnes étrangères
mais il y a aussi la possibilité de leur
donner la possibilité de travailler
c'estàdire que les personnes étrangères
qu'on rencontre nous disent qu'elles ne
veulent pas dépendre de prestation
sociales elles veulent pouvoir
travailler elles veulent pouvoir
subvenir directement à leur à leurs
besoins et au besoins de leur famille
eu elle cette question de de se sentir
dépendant d'une administration et d'une
aide sociale et de devoir justifier de
revenus et cetera c'est quelque chose
qui qui peut être vécu comme quelque
chose d'humiliant d'infantilisant pour
les personnes elles ont envie d'être
autonomees et ça passe par le la
possibilité de pouvoir travailler euh
c'est la question notamment de du niveau
des minimas sociaux aujourd'hui en
France nous on a on appelle à ce que
c'est imas sociaux soit
indexé sur sur le SMIC donc avec une
prise en compte de de de d'une inflation
qui est celle de l'inflation pour les
ménages les plus précaires c'est pour ça
qu'on demande une annexation sur sur le
SMIC on interpelle sur le niveau du RSA
aujourd'hui en France le RSA aujourd'hui
en France c'est 607 € quand le seuil
d'extrême pauvreté est à 807 €.
c'est-à-dire 200 € de moins que le seuil
d'extrême pauvreté le minimum vital en
France est 200 € inférieur au soil
d'extrême pauvreté à notre sens ça n'est
pas acceptable il nous il il nous il
nous apparaît que le RSA doit
êtreevorisé à hauteur de moins 40 % du
revenu médian c'est-à-dire au niveau
voire voire supérieur au SO d'extrême
d'extrême pauvreté donc 800 €. et on
interpelle aussi il y a un vrai
décrochage depuis la création du RMI il
y a un vrai décrochage du du RSA le RMI
était à 50 % du SMIC à sa création en
1988 et aujourd'hui le RSA est à 35 % du
SMIC et on interpelle également sur le
le fait que le RSA devrait être étendu à
notre sens au 18 25 ans je vais essayer
d'accélérer un petit peu pour nous c'est
pour et pour toutes ces femmes il nous
semble essentiel de de travailler sur
toutes les mesures qui peuvent leur
permettre de garantir à leurs enfants
l'accès à une alimentation saine et de
qualité eu aux vacances aux loisirs et à
la culture puisque c'est là-dessus que
qu'elle se qu'elle se prive bien sûr
énormément euh et euh et sur la question
des besoins de RPI c'està-dire que les
parents ces parents qui vivent dans la
précarité euh euh et qui et pour qui
c'est un combat du quotidien euh la
charge mentale et matérielle des enfants
euh nécessite d'autant plus des moments
où ils peuvent souffler c'est-à-dire
savoir que leurs parents sont pris en
charge dans des endroits notamment des
accueils de jour euh pour pouvoir avoir
des des moment de répi pour y compris
toutes les démarches administratives
aussi de recherche d'emploi euh de euh
des démarche auprès de la CAF et cetera
qui sont on sait de plus en plus
compliqué du fait aussi de la
dématérialisation des services publics
du fait de l'éloignement du numérique
des personnes et du fait de la
disparition des accueils physiques et de
l'accompagnement humain des personnes de
ces personnes là vers vers les les
services publics et et les démarches
d'aide sociale
euh peut-être un dernier point c'est
justement pour faire le lien avec enfin
ce sont des personnes qui sont
extrêmement vulnérables rture de droit
et aux suspensions vous avez interrogé
la CAF juste avant qui est
particulièrement visé malheureusement
par des pratiques parfois assez dur de
de de rupture de droit et de suspension
de droit et de demande de remboursement
enfin même de remboursement automatique
d'indu sans respecter le reste pour
vivre des des ménages il nous semble que
il est essentiel de de mieux travailler
à combattre le non recours aux
prestations sociales pour les personnes
à cessé la stigmatisation des
allocataires parce qu'en fait c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il y a du non recours
c'est parce qu'en fait la société
stigmatise beaucoup euh les les les
personnes alors que ce sont des droits
sociaux auxquels auxquels les personnes
peuvent prétendre euh et en rendant je
l'ai dit les services sociaux plus
accessibles et un un petit point
là-dessus c'est que vous avez dû le voir
un article du Monde à révéler des
pratiques de contrôle ciblé sur euh les
personnes les plus les plus précaires et
en fait ce que révèle euh ce cette
article du Monde c'est que une femme
seule avec enfant euh est
potentiellement à un score plus négatif
euh que que qu'un ménage composé de de
de de deux adultes euh pourtant à même
niveau de revenu euh et donc là on a
typiquement un quelque chose d'assez euh
concret à changer c'est-à-dire faire en
sorte que une mère seule ne soit pas
plus susceptible d'être suspecté de
fraude et de fauses déclaration à la CAF
euh mais en fait plutôt que les moyens
soient mis au besoins d'accompagnement
c'est-à-dire que si cette personne fait
une fausse déclaration c'est y compris
parce que le système est très complexe
et que elles ont besoin d'un
accompagnement beaucoup plus important
notamment dans les moments de fragilité
et de rupture parce que quand il y a un
risque de séparation et cetera enfin
quand il y a une séparation ça veut dire
potentiellement changer de logement
déménager payer un logement parfois plus
él un loyer plus élevé mais parce qu'il
faut absolument partir du logement ça
veut dire potentiellement passer d'un
temps plein à un temps partiel donc
avoir ses revenus qui baissent et en
fait c'est le moment où on a besoin de
travailleurs sociaux qui soi là pour
accompagner ces personnes pour les
accompagner dans les dans les aides et
pour éviter justement que ces fragilité
se transforme en bascule dans dans dans
quelque chose de plus de plus dur dans
dans dans la précarité et donc pour ça
il faut renforcer l'attractivité des
métiers du social évidemment et et
globalement un vrai plan ambitieux de
lutte contre la pauvreté qui s'attaque
aux raisons structurelles de cette
précarité en France ce que ne fait pas
le PCT des solidarités aujourd'hui qui
est beaucoup qui est très cosmétique et
avec des incohérences à tous les étages
mais on si vous me le permettrez dans un
second temps je pour éventuellement
développer sur ce point merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup y y a-t-il bah
oui nos rapporteurs évidemment
donc donc nous avons bah comme nous
avons trois rapporteurs je propose si de
de passer la parole aux trois
rapporteurs donc Colomb brussell euh
Béatrice Gosselin et Olivier Richard
donc bah voilà on va le faire basiement
merci merci beaucoup et merci à vous
pour pour la la qualité de de vos
présentations alors peut-être trois
trois éléments d'abord et pardon ce sera
un peu dans le désordre vous dire que
au-delà de de la présentation que vous
avez faite monsieur Badaoui et vraiment
je vous en remercie parce que c'est un
panorama extrêmement complet vous dire
qu'il est
aussi très intéressant de lire dans Le
dans le rapport les verbattimes parce
que vous adossez à cette enquête
statistique des vrais des rencontres
avec les personnes que vous accueillez
et je trouve qu'il y a des choses très
fortes qui sont dites par les femmes que
vous avez accueilli et accompagné
notamment sur la question de
l'indépendance de l'autonomie de la
dignité qui sont à rebour
de vision parfois un peu stéréotypée sur
qui sont les familles monoparentales et
notamment les les femmes quand elles
sont à la tête d'une famille
monoparentale voilà je j'ai trouvé qu'il
y avait des des des choses qui qui
étaient vraiment intéressantes et et
très fortes peut-être de deux questions
pour aller un tout petit peu plus loin
par rapport à votre
présentation la première vous avez parlé
du du non recours je ne reviens pas sur
ce que vous avez développé
sur la la la comment dire la gestion
algorithmique de la détection de
l'erreur bien sûr mais surtout de la
fraude évidemment et qui à la fin
devient une vision stigmatisante de des
familles monoparentales qui qui a fait
l'objet d'un article dans le monde mais
une fois que j'ai dit ça et je n'y
reviens pas euh sur sur le non
recours comment est-ce que vous avez
perçu soit statistiquement ou en tout
cas avec un regard sur les personnes
accueillies soit de façon plus
qualitative sur une dégradation de ce
sujet-là sur une stabilisation
[Musique]
euh bref est-ce que c'est de plus en
plus compliqué aujourd'hui dans notre
pays quand on est une femme et que on
pousse la Porte du Secours Catholique
plus difficile aujourd'hui qu'il y a 10
ans qu'il y a 20 ans de faire valoir ces
droits euh parce que c'est le le le
sentiment qu'on en a y compris je je
reviens pas sur ce que vous disiez
madame rigard mais sur l'impact de la
dématérialisation de l'éloignement bref
j'aimerais bien que que vous puissiez
revenir là-dessus
euh est-ce qu'il y a deuxième question
est-ce qu'il y a notamment sur la partie
garde d'enfant euh des propositions euh
plus spécifiques qui sont portés par le
Secours Catholique vous dites beaucoup
de choses sur l'hébergement sur le
logement donc je je n'y reviens pas mais
sur la partie garder accompagnement des
enfants est-ce que vous avez des des
propositions qui sont à entendre ce
matin y compris pour le travail que nous
menons et je m'en excuse vraiment et
mais je vais me permettre au-delà de de
la question des familles monoparentales
d'avoir un mot pardon Olivia sur la
question des femmes à la rue mais la
sénatrice parisienne que je suis ne
pourrait pas ne pas en en parler ce
matin merci pour l'alerte que vous
portez avec d'autres avec d'autres
associations collectif avec
l'accompagnement des des élus sur le
fait que aujourd'hui on a dans notre
pays des femmes et des enfants qui
dorment à la rue tous les soirs que le
chiffre de 3000 enfants au niveau
national est un est un chiffre qui
est considéré comme on va dire l'étiage
bas je je veux vraiment vous vous redire
et pardon c'est un peu le coup de le le
coup de gueule et le cri du cœur du
matin vous redire à quel point nous nous
nous mobiliserons tous les uns et les
autres pour que on cesse de considérer
comme acceptable qu'un enfant dorme sur
un trottoir et dans la rue dans ce pays
ça n'était pas le cas cas il y a 10 ou
15 ans et aujourd'hui on on a des un
système fou qui finit par faire établir
des critères mais parce qu'il n'y a pas
assez de place pas parce que la
bureaucratie a besoin d'elle-même pour
se nourrir parce qu'il n'y a pas assez
de place on finit par établir des
critères qui font que une femme enceinte
n'est pas prioritaire quand elle finit
par joindre le 115 pour obtenir un
hébergement d'urgence si elle est
enceinte
de moins de de 7 mois et qu'un un un
bébé un enfant de de 3 mois n'est pas
prioritaire avec sa sa famille pour un
hébergement d'urgence euh voilà et donc
vous redire notre mobilisation aux uns
et aux autres au-delà de l'urgence et de
l'ouverture de de lieux qui ont pu
exister ces dernières semaines à à Paris
et et en île-de-fance je le sais euh
mais vous red dire que nous ne lâcherons
rien sur ce sujet parce que dans ce pays
il est inacceptable il ne doit le rester
que un enfant une famille euh dorme à la
rue pardon Olivia
oui bonjour et merci pour ce rapport
alors ma question était même que la
tienne donc CIT pas grave c'est
concernerz donc la la fracture numérique
c'est-à-dire la difficulté l'éloignement
des gens des pour avoir toutes ces
informations et vous parliez et vous
l'aveiez euh enfin je pense je crois que
c'est une nécessité parler des des des
comment des
des des gens des personnes qui vont
aider tout tous ces assistants sociaux
qui vont permettre d'aider qui manquent
qui manquent cruellement et qui et qui
évidemment ne sont plus là pour faire le
relais humain de ces démarches
administratives et ensuite on peut avoir
cette difficulté de de de de de gens qui
finalement se trouvent dans des
situations irrégulières et se trouvent
sanctionnés et avec des des conditions
et des et des situations qui deviennent
vraiment difficiles donc voilà c'était
simplement ça je vais pas aller au-delà
de ça
merci je je nai plus rien à dire puisque
ma mon sujet a été couvert par Madame BR
je plaisante évidemment mais non pas du
tout on n'est pas obligé de travailler
en silo hein je je trouve que évidemment
il y a il y a un lien
euh madame vous avez je pense envie de
nous parler des défaillances du pacte
que vous évoqueiez donc elle
m'intéresse je je suis donc coapporteur
sur un thème qui semble en effet
effroyable c'est la part croisante des
femmes et donc des mères le bien souvent
qui dorment à la rue on a vu des
articles
horrifiant sur des maternités qui ne
laissent pas sortir les mères avec leurs
nourrisson puisque l'un d'entre eux est
mort
et heureusement mais comment pouvez-vous
comment travaillez-vous est-ce que vous
travaillez avec des structures qui vous
permettent de de de trouver des des
solutions et si oui quelle préconisation
pour parce parce que bien souvent
certaines institutions travaillent en
silo justement pas nous et et donc
comment faire pour pour coordonner
peut-être une action qui serait plus
plus efficace et permettre de sortir ces
ces mères célibataires ou ses famille
monoparental de de la rue avec leurs
enfants
merci dans un premier temps jeis vous
demander de répondre au rapporteur et
puis après je pourrais passer la parole
à nos
collègues j'ai essayer de commencer à à
répondre à à vos interrogations
notamment celle sur les chiffres qu'on
peut qu'on peut avoir sur l'évolution du
non recours donc j'ai j'ai essayé de
chercher
rapidement mais depuis encore une fois
une dizaine d'années euh il y a une
forte augmentation du nonreours parmi
les personnes qu'on accueille en 2012 on
estimait que le taux de nonreours au RSA
était à minima de 22 % et aujourd'hui il
est à plus d'un tiers donc plus de 33 %
au moins dans dans nos accueils ça
s'explique par beaucoup de raisons comme
Sophie a commencé à les à les citer ça
s'explique aussi par le fait que on
accueille nouveau profils de population
de nationalité étrangère qui en fait ne
demande pas les les aides auxquelles ils
ont le droit donc
ça à à contrario du du discours ambiant
qui dirait que les personnes viennent en
France pour toucher le le RSA ou je ne
sais quelle aide c'est eux qui de dem le
moins leur droit
euh et sur cette question du N recours
bon j'ai aussi laisser Sophi peut-être
développer là-dessus mais on est assez
impliqué dans l'association dans le la
démarche territoire zéro non recours
parce que c'est enfin ça nous remonte de
de toutes nos équipes c'est une une
problématique une des problématiques
phar de de l'association Le le manque
d'accès enfin les problématiques d'accès
aux droits des personnes qu'on qu'on
rencontre euh et sur sur les autres
questions je crois que j'ai rien à
ajouter sur les
chiffres tu m'abandonnes lement eu
peut-être oui pour enchaîner sur non
recours donc effectivement la situation
se dégrade nous c'est notamment sur le
RSA qu'on qu'on qu'on qu'on est à plus
de 33 % et qu'en fait on se rend compte
que la situation ne s'améliore
pas ce qui paraît assez compréhensible
étant donné la la politique du
gouvernement sur sur le RSA euh suite à
la loi plein emploi c'est-à-dire que la
réforme du RSA dans la loi plein emploi
ne va rien faire d'autre que d'aggraver
encore le non recours c'estàd que ce que
disent les personnes c'est
que c'est que c'est déjà tellement la
relation elle est déjà tellement une
relation de de justification permanente
dans un rapport assez humiliant et assez
infantilisant que cette question des 15
Hees au moins d'activités par semaine
non seulement ça va être extrêmement dur
parce que certaines personnes ne peuvent
pas faire 15h euh même même en fait
quelques heures et donc en fait tout ça
va se traduire par des suspensions du
RSA et des radiation et la knaf publie
des des études qui montrent que suite à
des sanctions d'allocataire du RSA les
personnes sont hors radar c'est-àdire
qu'on ils ne redemandent plus le RSA et
c'est terminé donc on perd y compris la
possibilité d'accompagner des personnes
euh donc donc il y a je il y a des
incohérences et c'est enfin notamment
dans le PCT des solidarités parce que le
PCT des solidarités veut lutter contre
le N recours en même temps on a tout un
tas de mesures qui aggravent le N
recours et malgré toutes nos nos
interpellations malheureusement on a
l'impression de de ne pas du tout être
entendu
euh euh la la enfin la prévention des
expulsions locatives qui a un objectif
du PACT des solidarités et d'un autre
côté il y a la loi casbarian euh qui
berger qui va clairement aggraver les
expulsions locatives euh donc donc il y
a un certain nombre d'incohérence comme
ça au-delà du fait que par ailleurs ce
PCT des
solidarités est dans une gestion de
l'urgence principalement mais pas du
tout dans que ce soit sur la précarité
alimentaire et cetera mais pas du tout
dans une dans s'attaquer concrètement au
au aux racines et aux causes
structurelles de de la précarité c'est
l'exemple d'une délégation je crois dans
le nord de la France qui nous dit que
euh un délégué du préfet organise euh la
manière dont collectivement les
associations peuvent aller récupérer des
patates dans des champs qui n'ont pas
été récupérés et donc là quand on est
face à ça honnêtement comme association
on se dit d'accord donc en fait l'état
maintenant est dans un rôle de
coordination de de de de comment on va
récupérer des des des patates dans les
champs pour pour pour pour pour lutter
contre la précarité alimentaire ça ça
paraît honnêtement assez lunaire dans
dans dans un pays aussi riche que le
nôtre et qui devrait devrait assurer des
conditions dignes d'existence à chacun
nos concitoyens ce qui est quand même
une promesse
constitutionnelle
euh sur j'ai un peu dérivé
entre non recours et et P des
solidarités par contre peut-être pour
rebondir aussi là-dessus mais qui est
quelque chose dans lequel enfin un
chemin qui serait bon à à prendre
justement dans le fait de de de de
développer des lieux accueil et de répis
pour les personnes notamment pour les
familles au Secours Catholique on
développe notamment avec les apprentis
d'uteuil des maisons des familles et on
vous invite bien sûr si ça vous s'
inéresse à venir visiter ces maisons des
familles voir comment ça se passe c'est
des lieux ouverts d'accueil de
principalement de jours euh enfin même
accueil de jours et qui développe tout
un tas de d'activités de de partage de
moments de de répis pour les parents
pour qu'il parlent de ce que c'est de de
comment dire aussi des ateliers lié à la
parentalité et cetera mais et donc voilà
c'est des c'est des lieux très
importants à développer le pack des
solidarités à l'intention de enfin en
tout cas identifie des financements dans
la convention d'objectif et de gestion
de la CAF pour développer ces lieux et
et on les encourage clairement et et et
vraiment vous êtes les bienvenus si vous
souhaitez venir dans dans ces lieux
euh sur euh
la la la question de la garde d'enfants
euh
h concrètement euh euh enfin on sent
qu'il y a les pouvoirs publics se se se
comment dire se s'empare un peu plus de
ce sujet euh je pense qu'on pourrait
aller dans quelque chose d'un peu plus
euh euh peut-être contraignant d'une
certaine manière pour les collectivités
territoriales on est encore sur de
l'incitatif et sur euh euh et euh voilà
et sur des guides de bonnes pratiques et
cetera donc c'est c'est c'est ça ne
promet pas non plus une un rattrapage
enfin le rattrapage qui est pourtant
nécessaire sur ce sujet
euh la question de de enfin cette
question des modes de gardeenfant c'est
elle doit être traitée au regard aussi
bah des emplois qu'occupent les femmes
et notamment bah des de ces emplois
précaires avec des horaires discontinus
c'est-à-dire que quand on enchaîne
plusieurs euh métiers euh très tôt le
matin très tard le soir euh aujourd'hui
les les modes de garde enfant ne sont
pas adaptés donc il faut qu'on
clairement avoir une réflexion sur sur
ce sujet euh et ce qui nous peut nous
inquiéter parfois c'est notamment le
l'angle parfois qu'adopte le PACT des
solidarités avec la réforme France
travail qui va au-delà de de la loi
pleine emploi on a l'impression que qu'
aurait une forme de enfin que l'idée
serait de réserver le bénéfice des
politique sociale aux personnes en
emploi qui est une sorte de priorisation
des personnes en emploi ou de ceux qui
accepteraient un emploi aussi on sait
pas lequel d'ailleurs quelle est la
qualité de cet emplois que les personnes
devront accepter ça un autre sujet mais
mais en en tout cas voilà une sorte de
priorisation pour les personnes en
emploi or toutes les femmes en emploi ou
sans emploi ont besoin de répi et c'est
les modes enfin le sujet de la garde
d'enfant c'est pas seulement un sujet de
parents c'est un sujet aussi d'enfant
c'est un lieu ça doit être un lieu
d'épanouissement d'enfant donc nous on
on interpelle sur le fait
que c'est ces lieux les lieux d'accueil
doivent rester enfin le l'accès doit
rester
universel il faut développer développer
l'offre eu pour ne pas avoir à
conditionner l'accès à ces à ces
endroits c'est un peu le même
malheureusement le même problème
que que les hébergements d'urgence
c'està-dire qu'on gère la pénurie en
trouvant des critères et et nous on on
on appelle à arrêter de de enfin voilà à
sortir de cette de cet impasse
euh
je vais du coup
passer sur les femmes à la rue alors on
a rassemblé beaucoup d'informations que
je vais pas pouvoir livrer intégralement
ici le mieux c'est peut-être que je vous
j'en fasse un un condensé que je vous
envoie peut-être toutes ces informations
dans un second temps euh par quoi du
coup par quoi démarr peut-être peut-être
parler préconisation du coup directement
euh donc parmi les parmi nos
préconisation on on on pointe la
question de du développement nécessaire
des accueils de jours dédié aux femmes
sans abri aux familles ce que je disais
notamment les les maisons des familles
sont un sont un endroit il n'empêche que
les maisons des familles aujourd'hui
enfin les travailleurs sociaux notamment
du 115 orientent vers les nos maisons
des familles mais qui ne sont que des
accueils de jour donc des personnes
arrivent dans les maisons des familles
en pensant pouvoir trouver un lit donc
ça met aussi ça nous met et ça met
toutes les associations en difficulté
par rapport à ça un point qui qu' faut
quand même Mme savoir aussi c'est qu'on
en est à un point de saturation des
services d'hébergement que les
travailleurs du 115 orientent vers les
réseaux citoyens d'hébergement mais ce
qui comprend aussi les squats
c'est-à-dire
que les les les adresses des squats
circulent pour orienter les personnes au
mieux mais donc ce qui met y compris les
travailleurs sociaux dans des situations
très très complexes y compris sans
savoir quel est le niveau de
sécurisation de de des squads dont on
parle je porte ça à votre connaissance
parce que c'est c'est on est dans
tellement dans de la débrouille et dans
la volonté de ces personnes de pouvoir
trouver des solutions à ces femme enfant
et aussi hommes que que qu'on en est là
aujourd'hui
euh le il y a il y a un sujet de de
d'investir enfin d'adapter de
réhabiliter les accueil à la fois de
jour et et et de nuit c'est l'exemple de
d'une notre délégation du SC catholique
à Marseille il nous dit que il y a un
lieu à Marseille qui est une ancienne
école qui sert aujourd'hui qui a été
transformé en dortoir mais qui n'accepte
pas les enfants donc en fait c'est juste
c'est c'est pas des lieux adaptés pour
pour pour vraiment pour accueillir les
personnes quoi donc il y aurait une
sorte de de peut-être de diagnostic à
réaliser de tous les lieux qui servent
aujourd'hui de d'accueil et de juste
avoir un programme de pour transformer
ça en des lieux qui soient véritablement
accueant euh soutiens les maisons des
familles je l' suffisamment dit euh
améliorer la couverture territoriale en
point d'eau d'accès à l'eau et à
l'hygiène euh évidemment on voit des des
des des bains publics réapparaître mais
en fait c'est il faudrait que ce soit
beaucoup plus massif notamment si on
prend en compte la précarité monstruelle
euh des femmes elles ont besoin d'autant
plus d'accès à l'eau et à des endroits
où laver les vêtements
euh renforcer les dispositifs d'allé
vert spécialisés euh concernant les
femmes et les familles à la rue
tels que les PMI mobiles la médiation
santé et la médiation scolaire puisque
en fait les femmes à la rue essayent au
maximum de de se
cacher pour bah de se cacher de pour se
protéger de de toutes les violence que
la
rue engendre et c'est pour ça qu'elles
sont difficilement trouvables et
difficilement enfin on ne sait pas
vraiment où les trouver enfin donc donc
il faut vraiment développer des
dispositifs d'allé ver pour aller
directement là où elles se trouvent euh
ce qui n'est pas forcément euh enfin
elles ne viennent pas spontanément
forcément à nous quoi euh répondre à
l'urgence de la situation hivernale vous
vous en doutez euh financer au moins
20000 places d'hébergement généralistes
supplémentaires en
2024 créer au moins 15000 places
d'hébergement dédiés aux femmes victimes
de violence supplémentaire euh et
là-dessus peut-être une interpellation
euh euh il semble leait que dans le
vluse une décision a été prise de
demander aux femmes de porter plainte
contre leur agresseurs enfin de femmes
victimes de violence de porter plainte
contre leur agresseurs pour pouvoir être
hébergé ce qui au-delà de la légalité
potentielle qui pose question de de
ça est un frein direct pour des femmes
qui peuvent ne pas être à l'aise avec ça
peuvent ne pas être à l'aise avec le
fait de se présenter à des euh agents de
police parce qu'elles sont en situation
peut-être irrégulière ou parce qu'elles
sont dans une situation peut-être de
prostitution contrainte et
donc donc voilà c'est quelque chose qui
nous a été remonté et qui nous pose qui
nous pose question
euh et enfin peut-être supprimer toute
hierérarchisation des demandes
d'hébergement à raison de la
vulnérabilité concernant les mères et
les enfants c'est ce que vous disiez on
en vient à dire que un enfant n'est
peut-être pas suffisamment vulnérable
euh pour pouvoir être hébergé donc je
pense qu'on peut tous considérer ici que
être un enfant dans la rue c'est c'est
constitué en soi une preuve de
vulnérabilité qui a pas besoin de le
démontrer euh réaffirmer le principe
légal de maintien de l'unité familial
euh dans les consignes d'orientation
passé au 115 c'est euh ce c'est
effectivement ces problématique de de
femmes avec des enfants euh enentré
basâge donc qui pourraient accéder à à
un hébergement mais qui ont aussi des
enfants plus âgés et donc les enfants
plus âgés ne sont pas acceptés ou la
question du papa qui doit dormir à la
rue pour laisser sa femme et ses enfants
à accéder à un hébergement alors que le
père peut voilà devrait pouvoir être là
aussi pour
soutenir sa sa femme et ses enfants donc
il y a beaucoup d'entorsse au principe à
ce principe légal de maintien de l'unité
familiale eu on interpelle aussi sur la
question de du programme enfin renforcer
le programme F d'humanisation des
structures
d'hébergement donc ça je l'ai dit pour
adapter le bâti et les projets sociaux à
l'accueil à l'accompagnement des femmes
et des enfants donc privilégié en
particulier structures à taille humaine
avec des espaces privatifs dignes et
sécurisants et des espaces collectifs
dédiés à la vie commune et aux enfants
et enfin la question de la formation des
professionnels des structures de la
veille sociale et de l'hébergement à la
prévention au repérage à la prise en
compte et à l'accompagnement des
violences faites aux femmes et aux
enfants et surtout le détail
euh vous on pourra voilà dans le
document on a des veram aussi de des
maisons des familles euh qu'on a un peu
partout en France et un condensé d'un
certain nombre de d'études récentes sur
la question de des des femmes à la rue
je pense que ça vous sera très bien qui
nous sera effectivement très utile mais
je vais passer la parole à trois de nos
collègues adelsan dans un premier temps
puis Marie Mercier et ensuite anque
billon merp pour vot présentation
merci beaucoup présidente madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup pour votre
présentation et surtout on va aller très
vite il nous reste quelques quelques
minutes moi je vais concentrer mon
propos sur trois points par rapport aux
éléments que vous avez évoqué le premier
c'est vous avez évoqué la création de
maison de RPI ça fait partie de ces de
ces éléments extrêmement important pas
seulement pour accueillir des femmes en
situation de précarité mais aussi
élargir je pense lorsqu'on a cette
situation de précarité les
problématiques de de famille en sit qui
ont un enfant en situation de handicap
tout cela cumulé dans les difficultés
dans les difficultés que nous
reconnaissons connaissons aujourd'hui
amène à une réflexion sur comment est-ce
que face aux défaillances de politiques
de droits commun qu'on peut connaître
dans certains départements dans le mien
saint je vais revenir sur un point que
vous avez évoqué euh c'est une solution
dans les propositions que vous faites
qu'il faut à notre sens développer parce
que ça permet justement au-delà de la
dimension RPI de travailler ce que nous
essayons de faire à la capacité des
pouvoirs publics de s connecté à la
question du non recours au droit au à
l'accession aux aid de d'informer ses
populations ses familles ses mamans en
difficulté de leurs droits là-dessus
j'ai pas pu être à la l'audition
précédente mais sachez que nous en C San
nous avons réagi avec beaucoup de de
véhémence à cette question d'algorithme
qui a été posée par la CAF le président
d'assè Saint-Denis a sollicité la
Défenseur des droits pour comprendre le
fonctionnement de cet algorithme car ce
que ce que constate et vous l'avez
brillamment présenté dans votre dans
votre rapport sur la pauvreté les femmes
en première ligne ce sont souvent des
personnes qui ne connaissent pas leur
droit qui n'ont pas accès à ces aides
qui ne savent pas pour des questions de
problématiques de euh de de de lié à la
fracture numérique aux problématiques
liées à la compréhension de la langue
française et cetera on est plutôt je le
dis pour notre département en Sani face
à des familles qui n'ont pas accès et
qui ne font pas leur demande de demande
d'aide en particulier auprès de la CAF
que plutôt des situations où on a un
algorithme qui qui va cibler les
populations les plus en difficulté et ça
je tenais à le à le souligner ici enfin
trisème point puisque le temps fil sur
la question de l'hébergement d'urgence
et de la problématique pour moi qui est
très connectée logement hébergement
d'urgence on a on a cette problème ce ce
sujet en scène Saint-Denis puisqueà
l'hôpital de La Fontaine des m en
situation femme à la rue isolée en
difficulté ont été dans l'obligation je
le dis bien dans l'obligation euh couché
à de la fontaine et ont bloqué entre
guillemets pardon pour ce terme les lits
les lits dédiés au maternité parce
qu'elle n'avait pas la possibilité
derrière encore une fois défaillance de
politique de droit commun d'avoir un
hébergement euh digne et en capacité
d'héberger une maman avec son nourrisson
de 3 4 5 jours et donc effectivement
nous sommes intervenus auprès des deux
ministres ministre de la Santé ministre
du Logement parce que il était évident
qu'il fallait apporter une solution à
ses familles tout ça n'est pas
déconnecté des proposition que vous
faites mais sur les moyens donnés aux
bailleurs sociaux pour remédier à
l'effondrement des constructions HLM en
particulier être en capacité de proposer
au plus précaire des solutions
d'hébergement en particulier pour les
familles maman isolées mère isolée
famille monoparental toutes ces
problématiques là appellent justement
des renforcements en politique de droit
commun dans notre pays voilà je vous
remercie
beaucoup merci madame la Présidente je
je voudrais vous remercier de votre de
votre présence ation et remercier aussi
le Secours Catholique de tout ce que de
tout ce qu'il apporte alors l'honneur
d'une société c'est de savoir s'occuper
des plus vulnérable de ses membres et en
particulier les enfants je suis plutôt
en charge de ce qui concerne les enfants
dans cette délégation donc là je pense
qu'on on tombe plus bas que bas quoi
laisser des enfants dormir dans la rue
bon c'est quelque chose qui est
impensable des adultes on n'aime pas du
tout c'est intolérable alors les enfants
vraiment touchent le fond donc je
voulais savoir si au Secours Catholique
vous aviez des analyses des études des
données pour savoir l'augmentation de
cette cette dérive absolue depuis quand
c'est ce nombre existe et donc augmente
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que la
crise du logement qui va aller en
slifiant en
fait continuera d'accentuer le le
problème puisque il faudra trouver une
réponse mais avoir une réponse il faut
déjà bien définir la cause donc
actuellement il me semble que face à la
pénurie de logement et bien on adapte
les moyens aux besoins comme on en a pas
et bien on va trouver des raisons de pas
mettre les gens dedans alors qu'il
faudrait faire justement l'inverse
c'est-à-dire de voir les besoins et de
considérer les moyens qu'il faut mettre
en face donc tout en le combattant parce
qu'on on ne peut pas se satisfaire de C
ces augmentations donc voilà j'aimerais
avoir quelques chiffres si vous les avez
je sais que l'UNICEF et la FCPE ont
travaill aussi le sujet mais peut-être
que votre votre approche à vous va être
différente je vous
remercie merci madame la Présidente
merci madame monsieur pour vos propos et
également le panorama clair que vous
nous avez dressé avec des pistes déjà de
travail qui vont forcément alimenter le
travail de nos rapporteurs euh deux
questions rapides vous avez parlé d'un
déficit de 20000 places d'héberargement
est-ce que vous pouvez flécher à la fois
géographiquement ces places puisque vous
avez dit que la situation était en île-
de France particulièrement tendu donc
est-ce que vous avez
imaginé à la fois une structuration
géographique mais également une
structuration par rapport à aux familles
avec enfant sans enfant ou femme seulle
et ça va déboucher ensuite sur la
deuxième question que je voudrais vous
poser puisque on avait une audition
précédemment juste avant vous et il a
été identifié plusieurs cas de familles
monoparenta et de femmes seules avec de
femmes seules avec enfants soit à cause
de la séparation soit à cause du veuvage
soit dès la naissance est-ce que dans la
manière d'accueillir et dans les
parcours que vous pouvez proposer aux
femmes et bien vous identifiez des
parcours qui vont être plus faciles
parce que il y a un accompagnement
spécifique je pense notamment aux
violences aux femmes victimes de
violence intrafamiliale puisqu'on sait
que le gouvernement a ouvert déjà et
dans la perspective d'ouvrir d'autres
places des places spécifiques qui sont
toujours associé à un accompagnement
pour se reconstruire donc est-ce que le
délai de sortie de ces parcours est le
même quelle que soit la situation des
femmme qu'elle soit finalement seule
avec enfant depuis la naissance à cause
d'une séparation ou d'un veuvage et dans
le cadre de violence intrafamiliale
parce que l'hébergement c'est bien mais
l'accompagnement c'est c'est aussi la
garantie d'une sortie d'une situation de
précarité de violence de de de c'est
c'est c'est la possibilité d'envisager
l'avenir et de de vraiment l'envisager
autrement que dans la précarité je vous
remercie à
vous euh oui pour essayer de commencer à
répondre à à à vos vos interrogations je
voulais revenir sur la création de
maison de RPI vous disiez au-delà des
femmes en errance et je suis d'accord
quand vous mentionnez notamment les les
les personnes qui ont la charge des
enfants avec un handicap vous avez cité
tout à l'heure les témoignages enfin les
textes coécrits du du rapport du rapport
que je vous ai
présenté justement dans ces textes on
retrouve beaucoup ce rôle d'ident donc
qui est assez invisible dans dans nos
statistiques c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut pas vraiment toucher avec les
chiffres mais en fait parmi les
personnes qu'on accompagne vous l'avez
vu par contre dans les chiffres beaucoup
coup sont très éloignés de l'emploi mais
c'est pas pour autant qu'elles sont
inactives au sens propre du
terme ce qu'on demande en fait à travers
toutes les toutes les recommandations
qu'a énoncé Sophie tout à l'heure c'est
c'est une reconnaissance des
contribution à la société de toutes ces
personnes et donc en particulier de ces
femmes et c'est c'est flagrant au regard
du du rapport qu'on vous a présenté même
si elles sont pas en emploi et donc
productives au sens qu'on entend au sens
économique elles apportent beaucoup à la
société notamment dans dans le rôle de
du prendre soin donc des enfants d'un
proche handicapé dans nos associations
aussi on a beaucoup plus de femmes que
d'hommes qui sont bénévoles et comme le
disait Sophie aussi tout à l'heure dans
tous les les métiers du du C donc du du
soin euh donc voilà c'est c'est c'est
cet appel qu'on qu'on projette dans dans
ce rapport concernant le la
documentation euh euh justement du
phénomène des femmes à la rue euh qu'on
sur lequel on se penche depuis tout à
l'heure en fait on observe qu'on a un
assez gros manque d'information sur les
personnes en errance de manière générale
euh on peut aller chercher du côté de la
Fondation abépierre certaines
informations notamment sur le le
décompte ou du moins l'estimation du
nombre de personnes sans logement stable
mais euh par exemple quand on regarde la
dernière enquête de l'INC sur le au
sujet des des sans-abris si je dis pas
de bêtises elle remonte à 2012 en tout
cas à plus de 10 ans euh on travaille
actuellement avec l'INC en partenariat
avec d'autres associations à la
prochaine enquête qui devrait se
dérouler courant 2025 euh donc on aura
plus d'informations mais si on a des
vagues d'enquête tous les 10 ans on peut
pas suivre suivre avec précision tout
toutes ces problématiques et et les les
documenter pour pour mieux les combattre
euh
sur le reste des questions je pense que
Sophie est
mieux pour
répondre
euh oui alors je vais essayer d'être le
plus rapide possible mais euh du coup
alors donc Raphaël l'a dit
on les les données que je vais vous
citer sont des pas des données du
Secours catholique mais des des données
qu'on a pu glanner à droite à gauche
notamment dans le baromètre enfant à la
rue d'Out 2023 donc qui est très récent
euh euh de qui a été réalisé par la face
et par l'UNICEF euh il y a aussi le le
rapport de la Fondation des femmes et de
la fédération nationale solidarité femm
sur la question des femmes victimes de
violence ça c'est aussi une source
intéressante en tout cas euh ce qui est
sûr c'est que pour la question de sur la
question des enfants enfin en tout cas
des femmes la en tout cas la
féminisation de la population sans
domicile euh il y a quand même une donc
on voit une progression très clairement
donc il y a une progression de 6 % de la
part des femmes concernées euh par euh
enfin son en domicile entre 2001 et 2012
donc c'est une progression qui est quand
même euh significative
euh et
euh le bar selon le baromètre enfant à
la rue
euh donc parmi les personnes qui euh
appellent
euh un dispositif d'hébergement
d'urgence euh plus de 6000 quasiment
7000 restent sans solution euh dont près
de 2000 enfants
euh et faut juste savoir que ce ce
nombre c'est juste les personnes qui
appellent le 115 sachant que beaucoup de
personnes arrêtent d'appeler le 115 euh
et les 2/ers des des personnes sans
solution sont désormais les familles et
donc c'est ce phénomène qui est qui est
effectivement assez assez nouveau
euh en un an le rien qu'en un an le
nombre de femmes seules avec enfants
sans solution a augmenté de 46 % ce qui
est énorme et parmi les enfants sans
solution 41 on 41 % ont moins d'un an
euh par rapport au territoiref du coup
ça ça ça connecte un peu avec votre
question les territoires qui connaissent
les plus fortes évolutions sont les
suivants plus 100 % dans le 92 plus 80 %
en hautegaron plus 65 % en Gironde plus
40 6 % dans le Nord
euh il y a je pense que enfin le le le
ce que vous citiez monsieur Zian sur
l'hôpital de La Fontaine vient d'un
article du Monde il me semble de du
témoignage d'une sage femme à l'hôpital
de La Fontaine il y a aussi dans ce dans
cet article un le témoignage d'une
assistante sociale chez Solly PRAM qui a
un réseau qui suit des femmes en grande
précarité et en gros qui dit euh le
témoignage de cette femme c'est en 2 22
on avait 37 % de femmes à la rue à
l'entrée dans notre dispositif 1 an
après c'est 60 %.
euh et malgré nos efforts en novembre un
tiers était toujours ou à nouveau à la
rue au moment de sortir de nos
dispositifs donc voilà et à ça s'ajoute
effectivement le le sujet des des
établissements enfin des des ce qu'on
appelle les
accueils mère enfant qui sont censés
pouvoir accueillir des personnes en
sortie de maternité et qui sont
totalement surcharg
euh donc je pense que enfin il y a
peut-être des diagnostics plus fins à
réaliser sur chacun des établissements
et y compris en terme de de de
structuration géographique
malheureusement j'ai j'aurais du mal à
vous répondre en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que au regard de ce que des
retours qu'on a des maisons des familles
qui sont à la fois à Cayenne à Nantes à
Grenoble à orléand et cetera la
situation elle est catastrophique
partout
euh
donc donc là-dessus en tout cas ce qui
ce qui est sûr c'est que on il y a
besoin de place d'hébergement
généraliste il y a besoin de place
d'hébergement dédié aux femmes victimes
de de violence avec un accompagnement
effectivement qui soit spécifique même
si je pense que c'est la formation de
tous les professionnels à cette question
là qu'il faut qu'il faut mener et il y a
la question des établissements d'accueil
mère enfant donc notamment pour des
femmes en sortie de maternité là on on
cible nous 15000 places enfin nous je
pens aussi d'autres associations qui
sont aussi spécialisées sur le sujet
15000 places supplémentaires sur ces euh
sur ces sur ces types d'établissements
euh voilà euh est-ce que et oui et juste
pour euh compléter enfin pour terminer
euh merci Raphaël d'avoir euh euh amené
cette question de la reconnaissance des
contributions à la société parce que je
voulais effectivement terminer sur euh
sur ce rapport qui s'appelle un boulot
de dingue qu'on a sorti en en septembre
euh et euh
et qui qui vise précisément à à
combattre l'idée reçue selon laquelle
les personnes sans emploi seraient
inactif ils sont loin d'être inactifs
enfin ces personnesl sont extrêmement
actives parce qu'elles sont
effectivement elles s'occupent d'un
enfant malade handicapé d'un d'un d'un
de quelqu'un en fin de vie c'est pour ça
notamment que c'est compliqué parfois
pour elle de retrouver un emploi et et
et elle souffre de la stigmatisation de
la la société qui les considère comme
passiv qu'il faudrait activer euh par la
menace de de suspendre le RSA notamment
euh et euh et nous ce qu'on on appelle à
davantage protéger les personnes qui euh
qui dont les contributions sont
essentielles de la même manière qu'on a
reconnu un statut pour les pompiers
volontaire qu'on a reconnu un statut
pour les élus locaux qui peuvent se voir
rembourser par exemple des frais de
garde d'enfants les soir de conseils
municipaux euh en fait il faudrait qu'on
reconnaisse que c'est ce sont des
contributions utiles et vitales à la
société euh que de s'occuper d'un enfant
malade ou de quelqu'un en fin de vie et
que cela donne droit par exemple à bah
des frais des remboursements de frais
des droits à la formation peut-être des
des droits au chômage des trimestres de
retraite et que on reconnaisse davantage
l'engagement notamment des femmes qui
sont dans ce soin des relations et du
vivant merci mais alors juste pour
terminer là-dessus nous avons une
collègue Joceline guidz qui se bat pour
ça pour que vraiment les accompagnants
soient reconnus donc c'est effectivement
une
démarche qui a lieu dans notre au sein
de notre hémicycle et que je pense
qu'effectivement alors j'ai pas tout
suivi sur les les 15 heur d'activité au
niveau du RSA mais ça devrait pouvoir
être tout à fait reconnu dans les
15hures d'activité et peut-être que
c'est lui suggérer dans ce qu'elle doit
faire le fait d'accompagner un enfant
Marie tu veux compléter à propos des du
handicap quand on est aidant d'un
handicapé d'une personne handicapée ça
ce n'est pas pas retenu dans les
critères pour obtenir le RSA avec les
fameuses 15h puisquelles font bien
davantage que 15h ces
personnes j'ai pas compris du coup c'est
pas retenu c'estàd que il y a pas besoin
de de dire qu'on a travaillé 15 he quand
on s'occupe de quelqu' d' c'est déjà
reconnu comme étant une activité qui qui
permet d'exonérer des 15 il faut quand
même il va falloir quand même prouver
c'estàdire que il va falloir prouver
qu'on a quelqu'un en situation de
handicap qui nécess s un accompagnement
pour pouvoir avoir potentiellement moins
de 15 he ou être exonéré des des 15h
c'est qu'on est quand même dans une
démarche de devoir c'est pour ça que la
fracture dont on parlait tout à l'heure
numérique bah ouiou on tourne en
r mais on pourrait prendre encore
beaucoup de temps alors donc c'est un
autre débat mais je vous
remercie je vous remercie beaucoup
de ce témoignage de votre rapport que
nous avons effectivement reçu et que
nous avons vont regarder et lu ou
liront avec attention merci chers
collègues de votre présence
et je vous donne rendez-vous pour la
prochaine délégation au droits des
femmes je crois l'année prochaine d'én
avant puisque ce sera pour la rentrée le
18 janvier et donc pour les membres du
bureau 8h petit-déjeuner et pour les
autres et bien c'est
à 9h
voilà pour le bureau 8h petit- déjeuner
désolé le 18 8h petit-déjeuner réunion
de bureau et ensuite 9h réunion de de
délégation